مساء الخير السؤال الذي يفرض نفسه وهذه
الايام هذه الحرب ضد ايران وشيكه لكن
الحقيقه ان السؤال الاهم
هلا وقعت الحرب وتتحقق مصلحه العرب منها
الاجابه عن السؤال الاول ان على الحرب
والشيء كامله الاجابه طبعا يعني مرهونه
باراده الامريكان واراده الايرانيين لكن
المؤشرات العامه بتقول اما الحرب ليس
الوشيكه ليست وشيكه لعده اسباب السبب
الاول ان طبيعه الرئيس الامريكي دونالد
ترامب اللي يقدم نفسه للعالم و للامريكان
المناخ بين هناك في امريكا بانه رجل صفقات
وليس رجل الحروب وهو يستخدم الضغوط
الشديده جدا جدا فقط كبار خصومه على تقديم
اكبر قدر ممكن من التنازلات والقبول
برؤيته لحل الامور فعل ذلك مع كوريا
الشماليه بهدف ان يجلس مع زعيمها على
مائده التفاوض
وقد كان
فعل ذلك او يفعل ذلك مع السلطه الفلسطينيه
بالضغط الشديد جدا اكبرهم على الطبوع على
القبول
بخطه السلام الا يعلنها خلال اسابيع وهو
ايضا يفعل ذلك مع ايران ودائما في الاطر
الاخيره بيتحدث عن ضغوط لكنه يعبر عن
تمنياته بان يجلس مع قاده ايران على مائده
التفاوض
فهو رجل لا يريد ان يدخل الحروب هو رجل
يريد ان يحل الازمات بطريقه الصفقات
والصفقات الرابحه التي لا تكلف ولا خسائر
في الارواح ولا خسائر في الاموال
تختلف مع الاوكرانيين على من يتحمل تكلفه
قاعده عسكريه على ابواب موسكو يبقى مش من
الوارد او انه يفكر بسهوله في خوض حرب مع
ايران
وفي حاله حرب مع هناك سيناريوهات يعني احب
اتكلم عن الحرب وكان الحرب تليها
السيناريو واحد اما الحرب اللي تكون الحرب
محدوده
ضربه مجموعه من الاحداث المنطقه بعنايه
داخل ايران او لمصالح ايران خارج حدودها
او حرب مفتوحه اذا كانت المساله اختيار
اهداف بعينها داخل ايران ضرب بعض مقرات
الجيش او الحرس الثوري الايراني ضربه بعض
الجماعات المدعومه من ايران في لبنان او
اليمن او العراق او في اي من هذه الدول
اذا حدث هذا وردت عليه ايران برد المحسوب
هذا لن يؤثر كثيرا في تغيير موازين القوه
اللي موجوده ما بين ايران ودول الخليج طيب
اذا كان السيناريو الثاني اللي هو
السيناريو الثاني اللي صعبه جدا انه يكون
مطروح على مائده
الرئيس الامريكي اللي هي حرب مفتوحه
هذا ايضا احتمال صعب حدوثه لانه الامريكان
لا يذهبون الى حرب من هذا النوع منفردين
دائما يذهب وفي وسط تحالف دولي
هذا التحالف ذهبوا به الى الحرب ضد صدام
حسين ذهبوا بين ستين دوله في الحرب ضد
بجماعه داعش فقط ستين دوله فقط لكن مع
ايران هذا التحالف يكاد يقتصر على اسرائيل
في المنطقه وثلاث الدول الخليجيه اللي هي
السعوديه والامارات والبحرين ما يعني انه
لا يوجد تحالف دولي ويسعى مستقر يتفق على
ربع الايرانيين والخلافات واضحه حتى في
تقدير درجه الخطوره والاستعداد لها وقائد
التحالف الدولي الموجود وهو بريطاني
الجنرال البريطانيه الموجود في العراق
ادلى بتصريحات الامس تتناقض ما يقوله
الامريكان الامريكان بيقولوا احنا بنت حسن
الى عملياتها تقوم بها ايران واذرعها
الجنرال البريطاني في العراق تحدث عن عدم
وجود اي مؤشرات على التصعيد من جانب هذه
الجماعات على الاقل داخل العراق الاختلاف
على التفاصيل والاختلاف على الرؤيه العامه
وبالتالي لا يبدو ان هذه الحرب وشيكه على
الاقل بالمستوى الذي يتخيله البعض اشقائنا
في دول الخليج وماذا لو وقعت الحرب افترض
الامريكان قرروا ان هي تكون مش حرب يعني
اه محدوده وتكون حرب مفتوحه الحقيقه انه
هذا السؤال السيناريو الجهه الذي يعني هو
لا يحمل فارق كبير ال ايران و للامريكان
ولكل دول الخليج طبعا لكن هل هذا يمكن ان
ياتي بنتائج الله اعلم لكن نقدر نقول ما
قدرش اقول اللي ممكن يحصل في المستقبل لكن
اقدر اقول ايه الحصل في الماضي الحديث عن
خيار الحرب
وكان وخيار جديد الحقيقه ب يخالف الواقع
والخالف التاريخ لان العرب بخيار الحرب مع
ايران بالخيار الحرب بكل اشكالها الحرب
الساخنه يعني الحرب العسكريه والاشتباك من
سنه ثمانين الى سنه ثمانيه وثمانين بعد
الحرب التي تسمى الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه
وطبعا حرب عراقيه ايرانيه لكن دعمها دول
الخليج ودعمتها الولايات المتحده هذه
الحرب لم تنتهي بالشكل الذي يؤدي الى ما
يتمناه العرب ماذا يتمنى العرب يتمنون
ايران مستانسه م سالبه تماما لا تشكل اي
خطر عليهم وكذلك هذا ما يتمناه الامريكان
ما تحقق شعب الحرب الساخره مدرب العرب
الحرب البارده بكل اشكالها اي اشكال الحرب
البارده اهم مشكله حصار اقتصادي لمساعده
الحرب في الولايات المتحده واسرائيل
والغرب طبعا حصار اقتصادي خانق جدا
عزله دبلوماسيه
اه وسياسيه كلام ده بيتم من امده في
السنوات الاخيره لكنه بدا من سنه الف
وتسعمائه وتسعه وسبعين
السنوات الاولى لقيام الثوره الاسلاميه في
طهران احد اشكال الحرب البارده هي الحرب
بالوكاله والحرب بالوكاله دارا ما بين دول
الخليج وما بين ايران ما بين دول الخليج
اللي ذكرتها السعوديه والامارات والبحرين
وايران
وطبعا على جانب اخر اللي هو الولايات
المتحده اسرائيل قائمه منذ سنوات وعلى
جهات كثيره موجوده في اليمن موجوده في
لبنان موجود في البحرين موجوده في العراق
موجوده في سوريا موجوده في ساحات مختلفه
وبالتالي فالحرب البارده تشكلها تمت جربها
لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يتحقق الهدف ولم
يتخلص الخليجيون مما من الخطر الايراني
كما يتخيلون على الاقل
فاذا فشلت الاسلوب الحرب ماذا يتبقى يعني
اذا كان العرب بالربو اسلوب الحرب هل يكون
المنطقي ان نتمنى تكرار ما لم ينجح يعني
تكرار الحرب مره ثانيه هي الحرب لم تنجح
ليه علشان ما ترى نفسك لاني ارجوكم ان
ترجعوا الى حلقه مدى ترفع ايران الرايه
البيضاء الى انه الحرب دي المطلوب من
ايران يصعب ان تقدمه ايران لا بالنظام
الحالي ولا بالنظام السابق ولا باي نظام
قد ياتي فيه المستقبل ايران دوله موجوده
وعند اهداف المنطقه عندها مصالح حيويه
اساسيه عندها مخاوف حقيقيه يجب علاجها قبل
اي شيء قبل ما تم الكلام هذا الكلام الى
الحل اللي فاتت ولا الحل التاليه ولا
غيرهم يعني اي دفاع ايران او غير هو مجرد
تحليل لما يجري من وجهه نظري ليس اكثر ولا
اقل
اذا كانت الحرب لم تنجح
من ال من من من المنطقي ان نفكر في الاخرى
البديله عن الحرب والسلام يعني ممكن ان
يتحقق سلام ما بين العرب وما بين
الايرانيين او ما بين دول الخليج الثلاث
وما بين ايران هلا هلا هل هذا السلام
مقبول يعني منكر وارد ما بين البلدين وما
بين العرب والايرانيين وارد جدا لانه كان
هو الوضع القائم حتى سنوات قليله او لغايه
سنه 2012 كان فيه سفارات لهذه الدول داخل
طهران وكان الوضع المتازم لكنه ليس من
فجرا وكان في سنوات الرئيس محمد خاتمي
كانت العلاقات جيده جدا ما بين العدوين
اللدودين المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايران
يعني في تجربه سلاما من بين البلدين هل
المفيد دول اخرى تشبه ايران والعربيه قيمه
علاقات جيده معها او معقوله نعم ايران لا
تختلف ابدا ابدا عن تركيا ولا على اسرائيل
اسرائيل اديك الدول الغير العربيه
الموجوده في المنطقه
القاسم المشترك ما بين الدول الثلاث نادي
والقويه وان الدول الثلاثه ترغب في
السيطره على محقه من الجانب العربي وقياده
العالم العربي وكل واحد من الدول الثلاث
يحاول ان تستخدم وسائل مختلفه للايمان او
للتدخل في الشؤون العربيه اللي هما دائما
بيتكلموا عنها فيما يتعلق بايران فقط ومع
ذلك
العلاقات مع اسرائيل علاقات جيده وتتحسن
يوم بعد يوم وبعض المسؤولين العرب يعتقد
انهم اخطاوا انهم لم يسارعوا في وقت مبكر
لسلام ساخنا مع اسرائيل
العلاقات مع تركيا لا تصل ابدا
تمحورت في المرحله في السنوات الاخيره من
بعد 2017 بعد الازمه مع قدر او من بعد
2011 الا بعد شويه بعد ازمات الربيع بعد
ثورات الربيع العربي
لكنها تظل على موجوده والعلاقات وتنوع
العلاقات الديبلوماسيه الموجوده مع معظم
الدول ولا توجد مشاكل تصل ابدا لحد
التفكير وليس التهديد بحرب مع انقره ففيما
تختلف ايران البعض يقول ان طهران
تمارس بعده في في سياستها والمساله ديات
فيها نظر صحيح ايران بتستخدم كل الوسائل
ومنها البعد الطائفي احيانا لكن ليس هو
القوام الرئيسي او ليس هو السبب الرئيسي
لكل المشاكل من طهران العرب واذا كان
البعد الطائفي هو السبب
فاذكركم انه سياسه انقره او سياسه تيار ات
قائمه ايضا على بعد طائفي لانها هي وتخاطب
السنه المسلمين السنه في كل مكان في
العالم وليس العالم العربي فقط ومع ذلك
فالعلاقات جيده مع انقره او ليست سلام عن
قرار ولكنها سيئه جدا مع طهران طهران
الطائفيه حليفها الرئيسي او حر فيها
الرئيسيين هما تركيا المسلمه السنيه وال
اه اه اه روسيا الارثوذكسيه وبالتالي فكره
وصفها بانها طائفيه فقط يبدو انه تعبير
غير دقيق هل يمكن ان يتحقق السلام مع اه
مع طهران نعم يمكن ان تحقق السلام لانه
تحقق قبل كذا طب هذا ممكن يحقق المصالح مع
العرب الفكره الاساسيه عند كثير من اللي
بيد الضروري الصدام مع ايران بيقولوا انه
اذا تركت ايران بدون رابع سوف تسعى
للهيمنه والابتلاع الدوله العربيه
والتغلغل فيها هذا الافتراض الحقيقه افترض
وهم الان ونطبق ايضا على اسرائيل وينطبق
على تركيه لكنه يمكن حتى اقامه سلام وليس
سلاما ساخرا يعني السلام ادراجهم الحرب
لها درجات في السلام له درجات في سلام وفي
الامس اخر السلام الساخره علاقات زي ما
بين السعوديه مراد اخوه وتحالف
وتنسيق على كل المستويات لكن في سلام يعني
السلام ده اليوم انه الدول دي لا تهدر كل
مواردها في الحرب وتضع الخطوط الحمراء
وتحت كل طرف يتحسر للطرف الاخر لكن هذا
السلام لا يتحقق الا بامتلاك الطرفين قوه
ردع
القوه ضد الاخرى يعني من السلام قائم على
حسن النوايا قائمه على الرغبه في التعايش
البلدين ان البلدين او القوتين يئسوا من
المواجهات التي لا تنتهي وقرروا انهم
تعيشه
بمشاكلهم بيحاولوا انه يقولوا درجه التوتر
ما بين البلدين بحيث لا تصل ابدا الى درجه
الانفجار هل التاريخ عنده امثله على ذلك
كثيره جدا
اقرب امثله للمنطقه ولايران هو الصين
والهند
الخلاف ما بين البلدين الكبيرتين وصل الى
حد الانفجار عده مرات وصل الى حد الحرب في
اكتوبر اثنين وستين واستمروا في حرب ال
عده شهور
هذا ما فيها الصين عسكريين الى الهند قررت
ان لا تتكرر هذه الهزيمه مره اخرى فقررت
ان تمتلك سلاح رضع الصين بلد نووي فامتلكت
ان الهند السلاح النووي منذ ذلك من الدم
وستين والى الان لم تندلع الحرب مره اخرى
بين البلدين لان كلاهما يخشى الاخر المثل
الاقرب الى المثل العربي الايراني هو اب
مثل
اعداد هو المثل الباكستاني الهندي البلدين
عدوان لا ندين وجرت بينهم اربع حروب
ارجوكم ان تراجعوا حلقه عن كشمير اخطر
مكان في العالم حتى تعرف تاريخ العلاقه ما
بين البلدين اربع حروب كان اخرها في مطلع
التسعينات لكن باكستان قررت انه حتى
تستطيع مواجهه الهند على قدم وساق يجب ان
لذلك سلاح رضع وقررت الباكستان وتحدد
حلفائها وعلى راسهم بالغرب والولايات
المتحده و امتلكت السلاح النووي لان الهند
دوله نوويه
ما ان تلك الباكستان السلاح النووي حتى عم
الهدوء او ال انخفض درجه التوتر واصبحت
فرص الحرب شبه معدومه موجوده توتر بين
البلدين زي ما حصل في بدايه هذا العام
لكنه والتوتر بيحصل بالبلد ان لا يصل الى
مرحله الانفجار لان كل بلد
البلدين يخشى الاخر لن يتحقق السلام مع
ايران بالاعتماد على مقدرات القرارات دوله
اخرى غير الولايات المتحده الولايات
المتحده لا يمكن ابدا ان تدخل الى حرب مع
ايران من اجل العرب يمكن ان تدخل الى في
حرب مع ايران من اجل حساباتها الخاصه التي
لم تصب الضروره في مصلحه العرب ان الحل هو
ان العرب يدخل في سلام مع ايران
واتفاقات
الاتفاق قائم على قوه الردع هل الكلام ده
السابقه ما هو السابقه العرب قدموا في
الفين واثنين والذي قدم المبادره وقتها
كانت المبادره السعوديه ووافق عليها العرب
المبادره مع اسرائيل ان احنا نتفاهم على
كل الملفات والان تفاهم تي معنا على كل
الملفات يبني الاسلام ما يعني انه يمكن ان
تقوم مبادره من هذا النوع مع ايران اذا
قامت مع اسرائيل فلما لا تقوم مع ايران هل
التوقيت مناسب مناسب جدا لان ايران تعاني
من ضغوط شديده جدا وعندها الحصار
والعقوبات الاقتصاديه ارهقتها شعبا و
قياده وحكومه لا تريد ان تذهب في الاعداء
الى ما لا نهايه والعرب كل قدرتهم مستنزفه
في الصراع على ايران وهذا الصراع هو الذي
يؤثر او العام الاساسي مؤثر في كل ما يجري
في سوريا والصراع العربي الاسرائيلي وما
يجري في اليمن وما يجري في الخليج العربي
وما يجري في العراق وبالتالي الوقت
المناسب ان الطرفين يمكن ان يجلس على
مائده المفاوضات
وابدا مفاوضات صعبه جدا لكنها لن تكون
اصعب من حرب غير مامونه العرب لم يتم
الزائر اما بالقرار الدرامي يا امه بطريقه
غير مباشره القرار الدرامي الناس كلهم
يعرفون مثلا زي ما حصل فيه سنه سبعه
وسبعين لما قرر الرئيس المصري محمد او
رسالات الوفاق المصريين والعرب والعالم
بان يهبط الى تل ابيب في مطار بن غوريون
الاسرائيلي
السلام معنى كده انا بحب العربيه مثال
امور السيارات انهم ما شايفينوا دلوقتي
وكان سابق عفوا يقدر انه ال ولي العهد
الامير محمد بن سلمان بما له من يعني
الجراه وقدره على اتخاذ قرارات جريئه جدا
او الشيخ محمد بن زايد ان يهبط بالطائره
في طهران ويخلوهم نقطه من اول الصدر نريد
ان ن ن هيك والخلافات هذه الطريقه او
الطريقه الثانيه اللي هي اقرب شويه الى
تفكير اشقائنا الخليجيين من تاريخهم
الطويل اللي هي الطريقه الهادئه ولو كان
انه يلجا الى ال ال القنوات الخلفيه اللي
ممكن تبرع فيها دوله في عمان لكن هذا
السلام لن يكون سهلا ابدا قرار السلام
قرار جريئ ويحتاج الى مواجهه التحديات
الكثيره اول هذه التحديات التي التي اشرت
اليها اللي هو فكر الامتلاك
اسلحه الرابعه اسلحه الرابع ليست بالضروره
او وسائل الرضع ليس بالضروره ان تكون سلاح
نووي مثلا خلال التي اشرت اليها ولكن قدره
على المواجهه على كل المستويات عسكريه
اقتصاديه التطوير التكنولوجي والعلمي بحيث
انه يكون دائما قوه مكافئه ومجابهه لايران
الامر الثاني هو اعاده السلام مره اخرى
الى البيت الخليجي
ومن هذه الخلافات اللي برزت بشكل كبير في
2017 لا يمكن مواجهه الخليج ولا يمكن
مواجهه ايران وفي ثلاث الدول الخارجيه على
الاقل لا تبارك مواجهه مع ايران الامر
الثالث وربما الاهم والمواجهه مع الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل وبعض الدول الغربيه التي
من الصعب جدا ان نتخيل تبارك سلام بين
العرب وايران لان هذا لا يصب في مصلحتهم
ابدا هم يستفيدون من الوضع القائم
الاستنزاف كل من ايران ومن دول الخليج
يعني انا اتطلع انا اسمع وجهات نظركم هل
تكون فكره سلام مع ايران وهل هذا ممكن
اخر ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]